DAVE THAU: Hi, I'm Dave Thau
from the Google Earth Engine
team.
And I'm here to tell you
about Google Earth Engine.
Earth Engine is a
platform for running
planetary-scale,
geospatial analyses using
Google infrastructure.
In this video, I'll introduce
Earth Engine and the tools
you can use to access it.
Satellites have been
collecting Earth observation
data for decades, but it's
been difficult to access
that information.
And there's so much data that
even if you could access it,
it's very difficult to analyze.
At Google, we've overcome
these difficulties
by downloading petabytes
of satellite data,
putting them on spinning
disk in our data centers,
and providing tools and an API
for analyzing the data quickly
and easily.
All analyses are run in
parallel across many machines
in the Google Cloud.
Our data catalog
includes over 40 years
of public satellite
data, elevation data,
atmospheric data, and more.
We also provide tools to let
you upload your own private data
or share it as you'd like.
We've used Earth
Engine internally,
where we've analyzed almost
a petabyte of data using
thousands of CPUs to create the
15-meter-resolution, cloud-free
image of the Earth that acts
as the satellite-based map
for Google Maps
and Google Earth.
Now we're providing
the same tools and API
to developers and
researchers outside of Google
who have been using it to do
things like monitor forest
cover change globally, detect
surface water, also globally,
and estimating the risk of
infectious disease outbreaks.
Earth Engine can be accessed
using a graphical user
interface at
explorer.earthengine.google.com,
which you see here.
And it can also be accessed
using an integrated development
environment available at
code.earthengine.google.com.
And it can be accessed
via a Python API.
Here's the development
environment.
As you can see, the developer
environment has four panels.
The upper left panel provides
code samples, documentation,
and a place where you
can upload your own data.
The center panel is where you
type and run your Earth Engine
scripts.
And the upper right panel is a
place for debugging information
and a place to view charts.
Finally, the map below is
where you can instantly
see the results of your
analysis on the map.
Let's look at the linear fit
example in the Code Samples
section.
Clicking on the code
sample brings up
the code in the center panel.
As you may be able to tell,
this code is JavaScript.
While the Earth Engine API
has both JavaScript and Python
bindings, the code
editor is targeted
towards JavaScript development.
Clicking on Run in the
center panel runs the script.
This particular
example shows how
the brightness of
global lights at night
have changed between
1991 and 2016.
Red areas have become
increasingly bright,
and blue areas have
become increasingly dim.
This example applies
a simple statistic
to measure change
over time globally.
The Earth Engine API
supports operations
that range from basic math
to complex machine-learning
algorithms.
We'll go more deeply
into both Earth Engine
API and the development
environments
in future tutorials.
Earth Engine is available for
free for noncommercial use.
For commercial applications, see
our Frequently Asked Questions
page.
If this all sounds
interesting to you
and you think you have a
good use for Earth Engine,
please sign up for access
using the sign-up link here.
Thanks for listening.
I'm Dave Thau, and I'll see
you in the next Earth Engine
tutorial.
[MUSIC PLAYING]